the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi everyone welcome to 507 biochemistry
online and dr. Bach danfa delish I'm
gonna help you work through some more
biochemistry problems today I have here
question two a problem set 8 so this is
a question I put together to get you
thinking about the electron transport
chain as you know the electric transport
chain is a fundamental redox process
through which we convert the chemical
energy of the covalent bonds into an
electrochemical gradient this
electrochemical gradient is like a
battery and it can be used inside the
cell to generate for example ATP which
is the energy currency of the cell or it
can be dissipated to generate heat we're
going to see both of these modes in
action in this problem now in most
organisms the electron transport chain
helps to transfer electrons all the way
to molecular oxygen however in this
problem we're dealing with an organism
that lives deep inside the ocean where
the atmospheric oxygen is not available
and it turns out this organisms
transfers its electrons to sulfate
sulfate is the final electron acceptor
part a of this problem I start to write
the order of the electron carriers as
they would function in an electron
transport chain for this organism now
for a number of redox processes the
problem provides like a table with the
electrochemical reducing potentials as
you see here now I've selected the ones
that are mentioned in the problem and I
put them into a smaller table here as
you can see we're dealing with
cytochrome a b c c 1 this is the flavin
mononucleotide this is the sulfate the
final electron acceptor and ubiquinol
now on this column here we have the
redox potential which are the
electrochemical reduction potentials
denoted by epsilon or e naught prime now
II not as you know from physical
chemistry or physics denotes the
electrochemical potential in standard
dishes however in biochemistry we use
the anak prime notation to denote that
the pH is taken to account and it's not
what you would expect like a hydrogen
ions concentration equals 1 molar but
rather is a pH of 7 the hydrogen ions
country concentration equals 10 to minus
7 so therefore these numbers are
adjusted to correspond to pH 7 the
electrochemical potentials we see in
this table are reduction potentials and
they tell us how easy it is to reduce a
particular species therefore the higher
the number the easier it is to reduce
that particular species and the more
energy the reduction of that species
will generate therefore the electron
transport chain will go from the species
that are hardest to be reduced towards
the species that are easiest to be
reduced therefore the order of the
electron carriers will be from once they
have the lowest reductive potential to
the ones that have the highest reduction
potential so now if we're going to sort
all these electron carriers in order of
their potential we're gonna get the
following order as you see here so the
electrons are going to flow from the
flavin into the coenzyme q and then the
electrons are going to flow from
coenzyme q to cytochrome B and then
cytochrome c 1 c a and sulfate and as
you can see flavin has like a negative
reduction potential it's like the
hardest to be reduced and the next one
is ubiquinone it's like barely positive
and then the highest number is sulfate
0.4 8 volts now let's take a closer look
how the electrons are going to be
transferred through this proposed
electron transport chain in the first
reaction here we have the flavin I've
written the flavin adenine dinucleotide
fadh2 a reduced version that's going to
be converted to the oxidized fa d
version of it and in this redox reaction
we're going to use the coins I'm Q the
oxidized version and reduce it in the
process so the electrons get transferred
from FIDH
to coenzyme q now in the next reaction
the reduced version of coins I'm Q is
going to get oxidized back to coins on Q
and in the process
cytochrome B it's gonna go from the its
oxidized form to its reduced form now
this process continues with every single
step every single Antrim carrier up
until we get to the sulfate where the
reduced form of the cytochrome a will
donate its electrons to the sulfate and
sulfate would get reduced to its reduced
form it's called sulfite alright so if
we were to draw how the electrons move
through this chain so the electrons are
going to start at F ADH
and then they're going to be transferred
to coenzyme q in the reduced form and
then coenzyme q is going to pass it to
the cytochrome b that's going to be in
its reduced form and then cytochrome B
is going to pass it to cytochrome C 1
and then cytochrome C cytochrome a and
finally they're going to end up in
sulfite another thing to notice here is
that except for the initial flavin and
the final electron acceptor sulfate all
the other intermediates get regenerated
so we go from the oxidized version to
the reduced version and back to the
oxidized version so all these electron
carriers are going to be sufficient only
in catalytic amounts so the only thing
that gets consumed is the fadh2 and the
sulfate these are two reactants and we
get in this reaction F ad and sulfite
some would just said will help us segue
into the Part B of the problem which
asked us to calculate how much energy do
we get by converting one molecule of
fadh2 in one molecule of sulfate into F
ad and sulfite respectively no as we
pointed out here only the fadh2 and
sulfate are consumed in this reaction
all the other electron carriers are
recycled and regenerated in in the
course of the electron transport chain
in order to calculate the energy it's
useful first to write the half reaction
of the redox processes here are the two
half reactions of this redox process
fadh2 gets oxidized to F ad and donates
its two electrons and the epsilon or e0
prime is minus zero point 22 volts now
this is the potential from the table and
that's a reduction potential the
equation as written is an oxidation and
therefore the potential that we need to
take into account is the minus of this
one sulfate is then gonna accept the two
electrons and gonna get reduced to the
sulfide and water and the
electrochemical potential for this is
zero point four eight volts so now when
we add these two together we get the the
overall process where fadh2 gets
oxidized by sulfate to generate F ad and
sulfite and the electro-motive force is
just the mathematical sum of these two
keeping in mind that this has to be
taken with negative sign because again
as written this is an oxidation this is
the potential for the reduction reaction
so the electro-motive force it's
actually 0.7 volts now we can easily
convert from the electro-motive force to
a delta g naught prime value and the
relationship is written here Delta G
naught permits
and F Delta e not prime and is the
number of electrons in the process as we
see here to F is the Faraday's constant
and Delta e not prime is going to be the
electro-motive force and if we go
through the number-crunching we get a
delta g naught prime minus 135
kilojoules per mole notice because it's
a negative number that means is a
spontaneous process as written and as
you know a negative Delta G will
correspond to a positive electro-motive
force now we're just one step away from
calculating how much ATP we can produce
with this energy as you know we generate
ATP out of adp and phosphate and this is
the the reaction that's catalyzed by ATP
synthase and it takes about thirty point
five kilo joules per mole to form ATP
out of adp and phosphate therefore the
135 kilojoules per mole that were
generated from one mole of fadh2 it's
going to be enough for about 4 molecules
of ATP s this is in contrast which was
the normal processes that use oxygen as
their final electron acceptor we're out
of one fadh2 molecule we generate at
most two molecule of ATP so in some ways
sulfate is actually a better electron
acceptor and can give us more energy
Part C of this problem deals with a
culture of this microorganism in the lab
and we're adding to this culture by
nitro phenol a compound
we're told has a pKa of about 5.2 so
let's explore what happens to the
electron transport chain of the organism
when we add the nitro phenol
here I put together a cartoon
representation of the electron transport
chain of our organism so as you can see
here this is the extracellular
environment this is the outer membrane
this is the inner membrane where we have
all these complexes I denoted here with
these rectangles of the electron
transport chain and fadh2 for example
it's going to donate its electrons
be passed along all the way to sulfate
and in the process protons are going to
get pumped into this inter membrane
space now these protons can be used in
the ATP synthase as they travel back
into the intracellular space their
energy can be used to convert ADP and
inorganic phosphate to ADP as we just
discussed in part 2 now to this organism
we said we're going to add the nitro
phenol
here's the structure of denied Ruffino
and we're told the pKa of this proton
right here the pKa is about 5.2 when
this compound diffuses through the
membrane is going to go through a to
this inter membrane space so it has a
very low pH and also in a in the
intracellular space on the cytosol which
has a much higher pH right so because
PKA 5.2 it's a relatively low much lower
than 7 PKA in the intermembrane space
where it's more acidic it's gonna be
protonated so we can write for example
that Ruffino
Oh H in equilibrium with a nitro phenol
Oh minus plus a proton okay now because
here we have a lot of protons this this
equilibrium will be shifted to the left
that is the protonated form of denied
rafino
however here in the cytosol the NP o h
it's gonna be in the same equilibrium or
minus plus h plus
but because the ph is fairly high that
is there are not a lot of protons so
this equilibrium is going to be shifted
to the right this equilibrium is gonna
be shifted to the left all right so now
look what happens so because this
equilibrium is shifted to the left it's
gonna keep soaking up a lot of these
protons all right then the neutral die
nitro phenol molecule is gonna diffuse
through the membrane as such and enter
the intracellular space the cytosol
where it's gonna be deprotonated The
Commitments to shift it to the right
so in effect fenetre phenol is gonna
carry the protons from the intermembrane
space in inside the cell now it's going
to do that in parallel with the protons
that we're gonna be flowing through the
ATP synthase to generate ATP so in
effect we're discharging this battery
where the constitution of protons is
basically our
electrochemical gradient is gonna be
discharging the battery without
producing ATP so as you know if your
short circuit the battery the battery is
gonna heat up because you're discharging
an electrochemical gradient similarly by
nitro phenol
by taking these protons from the
internal memory space and bringing them
inside into the intracellular space it's
gonna be generating Heat
therefore we can answer the part C by
saying that the medium in which these
cells are growing is gonna heat up when
we add the natural phenol to it the
process is described in this problem are
fairly universal now in eukaryotes like
more evolved organisms they would happen
in the mitochondrion if you look back at
this diagram if this was the double
membrane of the mitochondrion this would
be the inside of the cell that contains
the mitochondria this would be the inter
membrane space and this would be the
inside of the mitochondria or the
mitochondrial matrix right similarly by
adding a compound like diametral phenol
who can dissipate the electrochemical
gradient in the mitochondria and cause
the cell to heat up in fact this process
is actually used by a number of
organisms to generate heat instead of
chemical energy or ATP for example the
brown fat cells in newborn in mammals
have a special protein that allows to
dissipate this electrochemical gradient
in the mitochondria to generate heat
another good example is the the seeds of
many plants when they germinate they
actually generate a lot of heat that can
be used to melt the ice or the snow
around them that's why some of the
plants can start growing even before the
snow has melt and the early spring I
hope that working through this problem
will help you understand better the
inner workings of an electron transport
chain and how it can convert the
chemical energy of chemical bonds into
an electrochemical gradient which can
then be used to generate high-energy
compounds like ATP or it can be
dissipated to generate heat